Spring and summer is the perfect time to have an outdoor picnic.
It's a great time to get out of the house, smell the fresh air.
It's also kind of romantic, too.
Today, I'm gonna show you a few things I like to pack in my picnic basket.
Let's get started!
So for a light snack, I always like to pack a fruit and cheese platter.
I usually use grapes and strawberries 'cause they go really well with cheese.
Salads make a really great side dish for a picnic.
Today I packed a pasta orzo salad in these cute little jars.
They're portable, really fun-looking, and really cute to eat out of too.
And then for the main dish I like to pack sandwiches.
Sandwiches are great for picnics because you can customize them,...
...you can pack them individually,...
...and then also for the toppings, you can pack them on the side...
...so that people can pick and choose whatever they like.
Today I packed a chicken pesto sandwich.
And then for desserts, my favorite part.
I like to bring some cookies or brownies...
...'cause they're easy to pack and they're like finger foods.
Today I packed a dark chocolate with white chocolate chunk cookie.
And then for the drinks.
Today I brought some sparkling water and some sparkling bubblies.
But a really great addition to your picnic basket...
...would be some sparkling fruit juice, juice, or even soda.
And then to add some final touches.
I like to use real silverware and plates because it adds that homey touch to it.
And then some fabric napkins because it adds a pop of color.
And always have a fresh bouquet of flowers to liven things up.
And there's my picnic basket!
What do you like to pack in yours?